[Music]
please be advised please be advised hey
everybody welcome to the inte spoiler
app we're ready we're ready to go into
it just so all right so at the top we
always have to say this this is if your
first time ever listening to a comedy
film had spoiler up we're gonna talk
about the movie it and we're gonna talk
about the ending and key plot points so
if you have not seen the movie and you
don't want it spoiled for you I would
suggest hitting the pause button and
getting yourself to a Cineplex near you
we may even start with the ending we're
gonna start we got a start but first
let's talk about our ad supporter
frightfully uninformed a podcast that
watch his mostly classic horror movies
to figure out horror movie fandom
frightfully uninformed calm you get that
for the $50 level guys will read your
your URL your business on every episode
spoiler and one of the fans actually
tweeted a picture of their playlist and
it was comedy Filner it's frightful and
informed in conversations from the bits
fantastic so you guys are listening we
appreciate outstanding once you add
political vigilant at it please do all
right with us at the all things comedy
world headquarters is Dave Anthony David
how are around good how are you
now let's talk about it let's talk about
and first of all the ending [ __ ] okay
because really it's not the ending it's
really like the first half of the story
this is where I personally and we talked
about this in the regular episode but
when I was having problems with Bill the
length I thought it was it's 250 two
hours and 15 minutes or whatever and
they should have cut around 30 minutes
out in my opinion I was like if you're
gonna spend two hours and 15 minutes I
thought they were gonna at least cut I
was like all because I was looking at my
watch and I'm like it's like this is
they're gonna cut to 27 years for where
they're all like someone's going to get
a call like they're going to be in all
their different lives or
the country or whatever and someone's
gonna go right heat the wells back open
or whatever crazy clowns back so I this
is where I wanted was there a stinger at
the end of the movie why we didn't stick
around I didn't stick I didn't stick
around either I'm gonna see if there was
okay so with the problem with that is is
the books too long right let me know the
story's too big it's almost too big to
do the way they're doing and its really
a miniseries and that's what happened in
the 90s they made that many the the
adults but now I did have a question
because sometimes the rules got me a
little confused like I could tell like
oh no extras during the credits no extra
the only thing they show is at the very
end they go chapter one so they end the
movie on we've just started this yeah
and there was an audible gasp in the
yeah really well you saw the clown go
down the well they did they kill him no
because there's also a lot of people who
didn't read the book and just had no
idea that there's another part of this
you knew that's where he came from so if
he went back down the well then and he
was alive then he was back in his place
right I mean I didn't kill him so it was
like it was close to being the end of
his cycle the year yet his year yeah so
they beat him back this year but he'll
come back next so now my question is and
this may be this it gets explained in
the book like if they weren't afraid of
him like the girl who was a Rebecca or
whoever it was she wasn't afraid of him
so then he actually sniffs her so is
that something where he can smell fear
then he can't feed on her if she's not
afraid but then he opens his mouth and
uses hypno tonsils and then she starts
floating but she's yeah I didn't I mean
I didn't I didn't understand the
floating thing and like I assume that's
like the version of a spider using its
web to hold things that it's gonna eat
later but I didn't understand the
hypnotizing thing with the okay I didn't
either so that's that's what that's
where you get into Stephen King crazy
[ __ ] like there's always a Stephen King
in these sort of stories that he does
where it's just batshit insane
and so yeah cocaine's a hell of a drug
yeah Tommyknockers is like the best
example of how just batshit crazy a book
and go like you're just reading going
what just happened so he's got these
things in his books that that's like
that that you just kinda have to go
alright it's a it's a new rule so we're
hypnotizing tonsil yeah you know to me
it's just like wired he has a power that
that causes them to go unconscious and
then you know and then he can float them
up and wait to eat them later like but
that's how I saw you know it's it's like
it's like he's he's catching his food to
eat for 27 years you know right I mean I
did like these that was more of an
explanation that I got from the scene
yeah I mean it's one of those things
where you because of the length of movie
you can't really go into it what they
actually wanted to mean it's just kind
of there you know so then the the end of
the movie - were they the kids are all
floating around that crazy but they were
bodies I mean those were kids that he
already know he killed or he had them in
some sort of stasis like she he didn't
kill her but you know so that felt like
then they started to come down but we
didn't ever get like the resolution of
oh they've saved all these kids or
anything it was just bodies I thought it
was just bodies because I felt like
those were the ones that were afraid
that he ate and then this is like the
first kid that wasn't afraid that he
couldn't eat then he just hypnotized and
put up that's kind of the impression I
got everyone else that was floating was
already a corpse yeah they were dead
well there was a lot of except for the
zombies that were chasing them in the
sewer then what that one kid in the
sewer I think that was all imagination
or that was part of that was contracts
yeah that was that was sort of dear fear
and in him using his powers to scare
them got it right that stuff was so cool
the how it would the you know the the
clown would cater to your individual
fears so that picture that was so great
that woman had been decreed oh god it
was just like that was great it was all
I was just like so so creepy and then
she comes to life with the teeth right
and it was it was such a like
because that's such a thing as a kid
you'd be like oh god that photo that
painting creeps me out and you build it
up in your head and I'm afraid to walk
me I'd run past it or whenever I was a
kid so that the clown knows that right
and then taps into that and it makes the
thing come out of the there was someone
like she's she's having her first period
and then bloods coming out of the
covering the bathroom like right that
guy says well father couldn't see yeah I
know that was nuts and he couldn't see
her becoming a woman he wanted her as it
so he also can't see the blood coming
out like it's all related and it's well
done that was really well yeah and then
the hair was coming out of the sink the
hair that she had actually cut off her
yeah cuz her dad liked her long hair so
she's like because clearly her dad was
was molested yeah you know and so yeah
all the parents were awful the one kid's
mom the big heavyset woman oh really
overprotective crazy protective crazy
one she was just like that and that that
that pharmacy owner like that was that
creepy
pharmacy owner you've ever seen in your
entire life rolled into that one guy
yeah that was good increase so I think a
casting was good in this movement I
can't say for sure but it because I
haven't read the book in so long but I
believe it's like you know one of the
themes is like a cycle of violence right
so it's sort of generational in this
town and what's the parents robbed that
yeah 27 years so the parents are all
[ __ ] up because of what they went
through as kids and then it just keeps
the cycle just keeps happening right so
they're these kids who have no really
good home or support system so they're
the ones in life who are victimized so
that's who the clown is preying upon are
these kids who are not getting good
parenting and then 27-year then they
become adults and 27 years and then
they're abusing their kids it's the
cycle of violence that we have now was
there any more back story in the book
about the clown that wasn't in the movie
like where it came from like what I
believe we've created it it's just some
sort of spirit that was there I recall
an alien
it wasn't alien Hannah oh that's right
it isn't alien see that's where Stephen
King gets [ __ ] away
got a little it's just a [ __ ] demonic
clown alien yeah I mean it's not that
shape it's the shape that it takes but
uh and who knows it also takes a spider
and yeah the spider I remember so just
an alien that knows how to pray into
your fears well it it's it's taking this
form because our society views it that
as a weird thing but back in the day
like they were talking about the sixteen
hundreds or whatever whatever they first
then it might have been something else
you know it just takes whatever form oh
I see did the book have the thing that
the movie did where like when they start
going into the archive photos of the
city and you'd see like a circus wagon
in the background and then you're like a
creepy clown picture in the middle of
some old black-and-white photo from the
it had all that yeah cuz I really loved
that it was in the book but yeah he
painted the picture with words you mean
there's no pictures in the book it's not
a picture book
[Laughter]
how long ago did you read it first three
years ago okay yeah yeah yeah yes so
cool too cuz like in 11/22/63 he goes he
goes to that town as well so it's really
cool because it starts in a doesn't it
starters they're kids in the 50s right
yeah 50s or 60s yeah because they're
also did you know we did some research
on this and there was a lot of little
Easter eggs like when when Richie Tozier
is in the clown room right and there's
all those mannequins there's one of them
was dressed as the 1990 miniseries
version of penny wise that was Pokkiri
oh really yeah screen yeah which was the
creepiest room yeah yeah now you knew -
when you saw all of those sheets well
they're gonna come off in a second yeah
figures with sheets you're like only
evil is under those sheets I want to ask
you guys this so the did the the
interaction between the kids because a
couple times I was like it got annoying
and I understand like that's how boys
that age interact I have three nephews
and their I thought it was very real the
way yeah
maybe that was just me as uncle when the
kids came to visit there was a couple
times I was like just shut up stop
fighting with each other about
everything no no no that's exactly what
that was right yeah cuz that that's how
they talk to each other and that's how
they break each other's balls yeah and
then one punches the other one you're
like right they punch each other they
fight and then they don't and then
they're not yeah that's it was totally
it was I thought it was really well done
as far as that and then the the scene
swimming at the in the quarry or
whatever that was where they referenced
the turtle yes would you whichever Lee
featured in the book is that yeah the
turn what was the turtles what was the
turtle in the end of the book and uh
remember the turtle was like the good
spirit helping me yes but I don't know
what the turtle was like the so the the
clown is an alien now it's making me
want to read the read the book cause
I've never read it just to kind of get
all the this extra information yeah I
mean it's it's a good book I mean like I
said it's really long isn't it yeah
super long his books really go putting
the long ones they go really [ __ ]
crazy at the end and it does like he
says cocaine I mean it does have the
feeling of a guy who's just I always
always like to do it alarm anybody about
this what did you guys like have any
editor just roll their eyes
whatever that last chapter get delivered
it was it's so clear that at some point
the people just like ya know God do what
you want I mean he's doing like a
thousand page books every year yeah like
after he retired I'm not writing any
more books or retiring really what do
you guys think that like what were your
favorite like what were the scariest
scenes for your scenes that resonated
them up I'll tell you out of the gate
was really off putting in all upset yeah
yeah when the little kid gets his arm
bitten off and then just dragon in the
serum like oh my god game on immediate I
thought he was just gonna get dragged or
that it would just disappear no no they
rip his arm off and there's blood in the
rain-soaked Street right well you're
also like it's one of the few times in a
movie you're like it's a kid getting it
away
not kidding like usually you know if
someone's gonna get but I was like
now let's keep my kid away because they
would making a drag out so long and he
was acting in such a way they're like oh
he might not actually maybe help save
him for later yeah he just could this
kid might run away and then he starts go
over the boat yeah eating the arm was
just [ __ ] insane that when his mouth
opened up and I was like ah like that
was a the whole theater screamed yeah
and that one that was like wow that is a
great start to a movie right you knew
like alright this isn't this isn't gonna
like tease you I think the other scene
that got me was when they had the film
when the slide carousel when it started
and then all the images started coming
up like okay this is gonna get crazy and
then it's gonna actually look like a
movie but I didn't expect him to attack
them there through that yeah like I was
like oh maybe this is like a safe place
that you know it's daytime and but that
didn't matter and that surprised me and
I was like oh my god he literally came
out of the film
the idea of nowhere safe because it's
just fear so it grew from their fear and
it came out from their fear like that's
where it gets a strength well that was
the other thing the scene one of the
scenes that they creep me out the most
was when he goes on in the basement and
he sees his little brother who's been
missing for a year and his little
brothers like it'll float - yellow -
yellow - and then the clown skitters
across the water I was like oh man and
then des liked it you missed him yeah
yeah like thing was just like for me it
was when the the kid with asthma was
near the [ __ ] up house and they're
like balloons are in a triangle and the
clown was out back that was just super
fun there was a leopard picks up the
pill yeah so the balloon I feel like
there was more to the balloon in the
book like I ever was because I like I
wasn't it wasn't introduced enough for
me or wasn't explained enough like it
was in the library like remember like
when it was the bloom would always show
up when the clown was a
as I recall so it was like almost
foreshadowing that that stops any kids
like I'll [ __ ] the clown's around right
someone said they went to a movie and
someone released a balloon Oh balloon in
the middle of it it was a great idea do
you
and so then the other thing how is it
explained in the book in terms of the
kids are seeing these things and they're
not actually happening but they're
affecting them like they always like
come back to reality and there's the
adult going hey get out of there well it
is real I mean the clown can hurt them
and I don't know what the explanation is
but look they don't they don't have a
they don't have a parent to tell or go
to so they're really just dealing with
their own fear on their own so it's sort
of like they have to quash it on their
own or their fear envelops them it's
it's I mean it's about survival and
surviving abuse right so if you let it
consume you and overtake you then your
dust but if you fight it then you get
and don't let it and don't let it ruin
you and and become stronger than you can
beat it right right so I think that
that's sort of it can't hurt them like
the blood is real there there's
something about virginity though isn't
there in the book or am I just not
remembering that correctly yeah I felt
like there one of the reasons they [ __ ]
was it was something about virginity
like kids could hit like the blood like
they could only see the blood because
they were virgins don't even look at all
is what you're saying you may made that
up they mention it in the film they do
and I felt like that was an easter egg
that they did that I'd have to go back
and yeah I don't remember I I mean I
certainly remember that scene from the
book where they all take turns having
sex with the girl yeah being because
it's so like left-field yeah but I do I
remember pretty strongly that it was
catharsis for after yeah they didn't
imagine maybe not after they killed the
clown but after they they had gone
through something super freak I can't
imagine what the film would look like if
they had shot that scene and put it in
well that's still never one last scene
before it shifts
them being adults right I think in the
book it shifts back to them being kids
towards the end you know you couldn't do
that in it first of all then it's rated
acts like a show
you can't show kids having sex I was
wondering what they were gonna do and
and you know a blood bond they cut their
hands that's good enough yeah I can we
can end it be so weird if then they cut
to them all having AIDS yeah we made the
joke where the kid made that one joke
aids we're all gonna die like they make
that joke in there cuz it's the 80s yeah
and then again that's fear like everyone
had the fear of the unknown ages are
very much an unknown man it's all it's
all about fear the whole theme is what
were the two movies on uh that we're
playing the Cineplex it was Batman and
like lethal weapon 2 or something is
lethal weapon 2 was Batman and then it
came back and was Nightmare on Elm
Street 5 was on rise on the marquee when
they came back later yeah it was it was
the other thing that you know you're
Dave you're talking about the themes of
like growing up in an abusive house and
and how this movie was showing that that
the parents aren't safe that no one was
safe like that and also I like that
scene so there's the kid that's the big
bully and you really hate that kid he's
a bully and then you see why is it
bullying dad's dad's a cop his dad
shoots at this kids feed feet yeah and
he's like that's how you what is he what
does he say goes that's how you take
down a paper man just show a little fear
and it's play was was that in the book
the the TV show that was like really
playing kind of in their minds where it
was Pennywise creating the shows like
kill em kill em one of the first time
the TV show appeared in the film it was
saying something in the background that
it was like I forget what it was but it
was like sort of explaining what was
going on yeah it was literally it was
some weird backstory that you were like
oh wait that's what that I didn't notice
that yeah yeah first time it appears I
was like the TV show was saying like wow
kids you know it's it was something like
um daddy am I forgetting I just saw the
movie last night because they show they
throw some what it is but it was
definitely like I'm like wait they're
talking about what's gonna happen to
because I thought you was something like
well kids just you know people disappear
and it's okay or listen to your parents
or see what she tells them and he kills
his dad I was like yeah because all the
kids and then every that the show hosts
and then Pennywise is is chanting pretty
much kill him kill him kill and he puts
the knife and his dad's throw it I mean
it's a brutal way to kill your bully dad
yeah yeah now you never find out what
happens that bully if he falls down the
well but you never see if he yeah
clearly that's gonna be in the next
movie he's gonna come back as some sort
of zombie bully or something right as
I'm bullying so when you guys saw the
ending the chapter 1 ending were you
like oh awesome or I knew just because I
had remembered the TV mini-series that
there was a whole nother part of the
story where they were adults so it
didn't surprise me so but what I thought
this movie did a great job of is telling
a complete story with these kids at this
time for him like I didn't feel like it
necessarily left on a cliffhanger I felt
like I got off moving so now okay well
now I can see the second part of the
story and not feel cheated that I didn't
get enough when this first part I mean
the book is two stories right and
they're kids and when they're adults 27
years later it's that's that's what it
is so it makes sense to me does the does
the and then so then how are the adult
children of abuse themes dealt with that
I don't remember because I read it
before I dealt with yeah I don't know I
don't recall I mean I just remember that
the the girl is being abused by her
husband Ray and their marriage right Wow
yes of the cycle you know it's about
cycles right mm-hmm so remember they're
not they're not in great shape as adults
as I recall any of them which is which
would make sense yeah because if that
happens and you don't have you know
could help you don't get therapy you
don't have this an adult or somebody
coming in you know abuse aside if you
get attacked by a creepy clown when
you're a kid that's gonna [ __ ] you up to
clown attacks are bad yeah they have a
whole clown clowning on yeah clown a nod
well the interesting thing too I want to
talk about the film out of 35 million
dollar budget it's gross really yeah Wow
100 and 100 and it said 117 it's
probably way past that now
but that's we've talked about this a lot
on this show and I and and it's we
always get kind of excited because when
a 1 this level of budget when the 2250
million dollar movie does really well
because Hollywood as we talked about on
the regular episode it gets so hung up
on the 150 to 200 million dollar
big-budget superhero thing so like they
make these 5 million dollar movies and
then they make these 150 million dollar
movies so when they make a thing like
this it was 35 million and it was really
obviously was on a lot of special
effects cuz it's not like it's littered
with big-name stars well I mean no not
at all it was like a lot of practical
effects we're really really cool and
practical effects are creepy as [ __ ] and
it proves that you don't need stars to
make a successful horror movie the other
thing that's an anomaly about this film
is Studios big studios generally don't
know how to do horror
they're usually awful when they do
horror movies and how many Stephen King
books have they ruined write another one
this year the Dark Tower was terrible
and the innovation and the interesting
things in horror has usually been the
indie horror movie yeah but this is this
one time where this is a decent budget
studio horror movie that actually
delivered because I really feel like it
took the lessons of the indie horror
movies and applied them to a big-budget
studio movie yeah and I think the lesson
they applied correctly was this is a
property that people everybody knows
this book because the evidence in that
to the first teaser trailer that they
released for this got 197 million views
online right hit it really yeah it reads
Fast and the Furious the fate of the
Furious which had 139 million views
really so I think wow guys like all the
people that I also watched it three
times cuz the trailer was so [ __ ] good
yeah
exactly they they had a property that
people loved I don't think anyone
remembers the open you know the one from
the 90s whatever but everybody knows the
book
everybody knows Stephen King and then
they cut together the creepiest goddamn
trailer Hwy so how many how many horror
trailers have we watched on this show
and gone though like I've seen it got it
you know it's the same trailer and it's
like the KITT creepy kid being around
yeah and then there's silence and then
the thing there's always the shot like
he's in there and then you see you lift
up the sheets and oh god it's in the bed
with you yeah the camera pans back well
there's gonna be something there yeah I
wonder what's gonna be in the mirror of
your reflection no um so yeah this
trailer was like oh and it wasn't just
straight horror it was like they took
the time to develop the character sue
sue actually cared about the characters
and it wasn't yeah that was the thing
about all those kids dialogue was they
were really building those characters
really well yeah they were building the
characters well and and they were fully
formed you know 14 year olds or whatever
they're you know what's interesting to
me is where the I guess they were 14
right at 13 for somewhere in there so
you got that you got the the the black
kid his parents have died you got the
girl was being abused the kid with the
glasses do we know what his deal was
that was the one kid I don't think we
got much we got me stranger things kid
yeah yeah and you got the kid with
munchausen syndrome where his mom is
acting like he's sick and then you got
the and then you get the sort of main
character kid his brothers died from the
cry on who has a stutter yeah it stands
out to me I want to go so is the Jewish
kid just [ __ ] up because he's Jewish
like what there was nothing he had like
no just had to do that was like he
didn't I guess was his dad uncaring or
yeah that was the one scene where it
wasn't that brutal of a home environment
it was his dad was just like come on I'm
you're not reading this book right right
that's all there was
he says what's it gonna look like the
rabbi's kid doesn't know the Torah I
mean I was like alright well that dad is
just it's just was it cuz he's from a
very religious fan
like I just didn't I was like I don't
know what that one is that lost me that
one wasn't like oh that creeps me out
like no I could see that yeah yeah that
was normal yeah your dad's irritating
because he didn't do it you were
supposed to fine just take the book
you're writing yeah like just just go
past the creepy picture that's your
punishment yeah well what else what
other thing before we wrap this episode
up what are you guys I'm looking forward
to the next one for sure I really
thought this was a this is a good
example of how you can update a property
like you know the 90s I'm sure if we
watch that miniseries now it would not
hold oh god it's just Harry Anderson and
John magic there's a good sleight of
hand the penny wise cartridge if any was
where you know this is a property they
they obviously took some liberties with
the time frame but that's fine and they
did a good job updating it you know yeah
and they get what they did they did
several good things they did a good job
updating it but then somebody like
myself haven't read the book didn't know
much about it yeah overall fine like I
said my one little and this is just more
of an Nikki gripe a little too long for
me sure but that might just be because
I've watched way too many movies so I
just write you have things to do yeah
when places to be and also for me for
someone who I don't if I read a book I
don't like to see the movie this is the
kind of movie I want to see cuz it's a I
want to see the creepy clown usually
it's a story that I'm again well I know
the story so I don't want to see it but
this one my gonna see the [ __ ] crazy
clown right and how they executed all of
the nightmares was was great was so cool
was so innovative was creepy and scary
they did a great job too with the music
the music and sound design that's so
important in horror like it really is
important the creepy sound or the like
some little thing like that and they did
it in ways that were some of them were
really sort of inventive to me that was
like this this doesn't feel like just
sort of your standard oh well we got to
have a you know the adore blow shot or a
cat or something stupid like that it was
really cuz this thing like you said Dave
it was all about fear and facing your
fears and when you don't you know when
you
let your feelers consume you they get
bigger and stronger and more powerful
that was always me overtaking or or
don't recognize what you should be
afraid of like the older bully kid who
got taken out it's cuz he was ignoring
his fear right right that's true he was
just like Oh fine yeah I'm better than
this and not like just being like I
should be a little cautious here yes
exactly and that's a good point and the
the sewer pipe line thing yeah was was
again there's a no there's another
example of a parent that wasn't that bad
that was actually a reasonable parent
the kid whose brother lost the domaine
kid oh yeah and he comes in the garage
and the dads like didn't we talk about
this he's like no dad and he gives the
example of the and that was the one
adult that I was like well this is a dad
who's just like man my son won't let go
long brother why and I gotta get him I
gotta get him through this my wife is
going nuts over this that was the one I
was like oh he's being a reasonable
parent Yeah right
he wasn't like awful and of course but
then but then the great thing is it's
that is that story of the kid was right
yeah yeah yeah but what's he gonna do
come home okay dad look I know we saw
that there was a clown and a hole
everybody's floating yeah hello to dad
but I assume that then I assume I don't
know what happens but like they then all
those bodies came down so then the town
would find all those bodies right right
cuz then the clown is going back to heal
for 27 years yes so those bodies are
there so they're there was a in the next
movie there will have been a big killer
that they didn't catch that was in the
town yeah and that's the other thing
does and is that part of this and when
we went into the history of all there
was this big fire and this other thing
is that what the town does is they go oh
the clowny you know Pennywise cradled a
bunch of people so we're gonna say it
was a train derailed like is the whole
town get together and cover up Pennywise
is horror no I think it was just cereal
they just think it was some sort of
serial killer as I recall I always
wondered you know there was a there was
a
I think was in Michigan there was a some
anarchist blew up a school
they killed like [ __ ] 80 kids or
something in the early 1900s and I
always wonder if his idea came from that
also Oh inspiration yeah Stephen King
more he just was probably abused yeah
right I mean the clowns team the hated
clowns yeah I think he had a pretty good
probably having a pretty dark childhood
is my guess yeah I mean there's no way
he didn't I mean he's just reveling in
[ __ ] horror all right
anything else that's a good wrap-up for
sure
looking forward to the next installment
yeah I'm in and I like you said it'll
probably be two years they'll probably
start shooting and then it'll be out and
that's good I can watch one horror movie
every two years right I hope they don't
get big stars I hope that because now
people are gonna want to do it because
the first one was yeah exactly I hope
they don't if they do I hope they really
cast it well I hope it's like Mark
Ruffalo or somebody that's like a really
skilled actor that can play the nuances
of of the adult version of a kid like
cuz you the actor would have to fill in
just internal is good Chastain or
somebody yeah that you would have to
fill in the 27 years as the an ER to
bring that across be court where you
would because we all know like and and
if you've like been through abuse as I
have and you have David you then you you
start to remember points in your life
where you're like oh that's why I acted
yeah yeah yeah I didn't realize that
yeah that's how that makes sense and so
the adult realization because they're
gonna be in their 40s right if they're
15 13 14 15 years old and 27 years later
they're gonna be at that age where you
start like oh god or you remember stuff
or whatever and so if you cast it if you
just go a list to sell tickets that's a
mistake no I agree but if you get skill
really skilled actors I mean like like
look at spotlight a lot of big-name
actors in that and they were [ __ ]
amazing amazing you know so if you cast
it that way then then it could it could
really
there's actors and then there's stars
right right right and then there's also
all these guys then who were were
childhood actors on shitty shows and
they just keep kicking it around a hall
like the Zac Efron's of the [ __ ]
world you put someone like that in and
you're just [ __ ] look they have to be
actors yes so you're saying Zac Efron
and Seth Rogen and all those guys and
just make it like neighbors just a
college romp I would like to see Seth
Rogen find a clown all right well Dave
Anthony where can people find on the
internet your podcast I'm at Dave
Anthony on Twitter my podcast is the
dollop my album is called hothead on
iTunes of bang camp
nice and then of course Los Angeles
podcast festival October 6th through the
8th get tickets at LA pod fest calm guys
it's at the Biltmore Hotel downtown
which is a fan it's it's I'm not just
saying this it's the coolest venue we've
had yeah for sure and and you'll see
comedy film where it's in the dark life
doing it live during the first ever
political vigilante live we've got some
of your favorite podcasts that have been
in every year some new ones we always
try to mix it up yeah you guys are fans
it's chavo house right chapo Trap House
Joe Joe that's the first time they've
been in and the podcast pros thing if
you're if you're into like if you're a
new podcast or you want to get into the
podcast business or whatever it's gonna
be a lot of great information it's not
just in the past we've just had some
panels that were cool and informative
but a lot of you were like we want more
right now it's the whole program you
could go literally Friday to Sunday and
just have just do panels and workshops
yeah it's in a special part of the hotel
and and it's cool and the downtown area
is cool and and so go to LA pod fest
com2 get your tickets there's no live
stream guys it didn't make enough money
last year so it we can't do lost money
so we're actually making money by not
doing it so this as we said this isn't
just a idle threat or whatever the
festival needs to have a decent year to
come back if it doesn't we can't do it
anymore because we can't compete with
giant billionaire corporations that
charge you $400 for a weekend pass if
you can go down the street - yeah yeah
only if you only if your
female can you go to an exclusion it's a
festival that excludes baseball people
our transgender people not allowed in
that festival either oh my god yeah
you know like what is interesting yeah
so I'm I'm a woman that trans pudding
became a man
I'm not allowed now I don't think so
great festival you can go part time yeah
if you hate inclusion and everybody's
welcome then don't come to LA pod fest
because we've been making it for
everybody for the last or every
podcaster for you know anyway that's why
we have the lab so even if you're not
programming the festival you can
actually record don't care what your
gender is or we just want you to
identify as a podcast fan that's the
only thing you need to identify you
actually see the three of us walking
around we'll be there the entire time
we'll hang out at parties and it'll be a
lot of fun and inclusive as always and
it's a great cool we're awesome you know
go to the website at the Biltmore and
see it's really cool it's got a lot of
character it's it's it's our coolest
venue so it's in ghostbusters it's the
original the original it's supposed to
be New York City that hotel right they
shot it the marc maron will be doing
stand-up at the stand-up show oh gastic
just recently announced we're gonna so
there's the stand-up show and we might
we don't know yet but we might make that
a single ticketed event because they
have a big like 900 seat room and so
like Jackie Kashian is performing there
Laura house is performing there Todd
glass Marc Maron I'll be performing
already a great show already a fantastic
show so go to LA pod fest com
Thank You Erin bran guard and everybody
at the ATC worldwide headquarters in
beautiful Burbank California my name is
Graham Elwood and I'm Chris Mancini and
it's always remember Han shot first
you'll float - you'll float ooh you'll
float
you